tell me a little bit about your life
what's what's going on I mean uh tell us
a little bit about yourself Avril at the
moment I'm
working most most days I'm working on a
Hulu show at the moment which is pretty
cool okay
um but I mean your social life your my
social life yeah it can't all be work
you know yeah is there uh you know yeah
do you have a tick
do I have a tick
I don't even know what that means is
there a horse living with you is there a
yeah you know what I mean you know hey
are you seeing anybody right now are you
married I'm just curious these are
because this isn't a job interview I'm
allowed to ask yeah of course you are
um no there is not I am alone
okay
no
um it's going pretty slowly the old
dating life do people use the apps in
Ireland I imagine they do just like they
do here in America yes they do yes
um I use them in the wrong way though
because I look for people that I already
know
um before what you're you're going on
the apps for a date but you exclude
yourself to people you already know yes
why do you do that
um I just I'm afraid of strangers I get
it I don't like I don't like strangers
right and I feel like if I already know
them you know I don't have to do that
awkward get to know you date I get to
like skip to the second one right right
you know what I mean sure yeah what
happens if on the app you express your
interest in them and you already know
them and what if they don't like uh you
know
reciprocate or vice versa and then you
see each other again and you're like oh
yeah is that awful well that's the
that's the trick you can't do that you I
don't do that okay right I let them come
to me but if they don't come to me then
I forget about us because okay it's too
risky I got you okay Avril I'm gonna um
really bore down here with some
questions because yeah first of all tell
me what kind of person you're looking
for what's your type so funny
um hopefully musical kind of right
um lots of hair I like lots of hair okay
on the head okay yeah and just not
you're like you have to get through a
lot of the same man on Dating apps in
Ireland I don't know if it's the same in
us but especially in Dublin there's just
that this one guy who's just over and
over again the same is it literally just
one creep who's keeps multiple programs
no no describe yes
but tell us what is the type what is the
what is the Irish the typical Irish guy
on an app describe him so we have
um loves sea swimming Sea swimming I'm
just guessing means loves to swim in the
sea yes but it's a thing here and it's
sea swimming and um over the pandemic
people started doing it a lot because it
was the only thing that people could do
to meet other people because it was
literally in the sea right
um and then people kept it going
afterwards and they've made it their
entire personality so they're a bunch of
tunes out there that are all into sea
swimming yes
and that's fine but I seem to be getting
the same answers every time to like the
prompts on hinge so it's like if you're
into sea swimming we'll get along if you
like drinking Guinness we'll get along
and I don't know if those are enough to
like start a relationship no I like the
sound I mean it sounds a little if a guy
is saying if you if you're asking
someone essentially who are you and he
says I like to jump into the cold Irish
sea and I like drinking Guinness
um I don't know if you're hearing that
again and again and again it doesn't
sound like it's not a lot to go on no so
to combat that I Photoshop my head onto
a picture of someone being interviewed
by you on your show what and I use that
this sounds very deceitful you took your
head and you put it on the body of
someone I was interviewing
um yes and uh who was it I was
interviewing which body did you um it
was the guy from Bill and Ted
Keanu Reeves not Keanu Reeves Alex
Winter
why did you do that I thought you meant
it would be another woman that kind of
looked like yes yeah no that was because
that's what I don't want to trick people
like genuinely trick people but I want
people to stop and go wait a second and
they're like oh wait no she didn't but
she did this thing that's a real fetish
out there uh someone who's got the face
of an attractive young woman and the
body of Alex Winter that's a known
I mean I've spent a lot of time on
fetish sites and that is a big one
because it doesn't exist anymore okay
yeah so it's a real hot commodity
very very I can only wish to have the
body of Alex Winter
um I wish well I do it's in the trunk of
my car uh I killed him weeks ago
turn Avril
try and pull this together here okay
you're living in Dublin you are a very
uh funny uh uh uh cool person and you've
got good a good job uh and I think uh
you've you've got everything going for
you and I feel that it's my mission now
to to find you the right person and I
worry if you're all if you're not taking
any chances if you're only talking to
guys who are already your friend I don't
know that I think you're trapping
yourself in in the friend zone don't you
agree so well I think there's a reason
maybe there wasn't anything romantic in
the first place right yeah so maybe if
you're going back to that well I don't
know yeah that's dry yeah so you may
have to take a little bit of a risk and
risk uh maybe a not a great first date
and then there's no other date I think
you need to risk bad first dates are fun
yeah they can be fun yeah yeah they're a
fun story yeah I've had so many bad
first day oh let me tell you uh Sono was
a disaster for years when she was
working for me she would go on these
terrible dates with these complete
losers and then be humiliated and it
happened again and again and again and
again and again okay yeah we get it we
get it we get it we get it well I
noticed when you were listing off the
things that you wanted you didn't say
that he needs to have a job and that was
my thing was that they didn't really
have to have a job I was all about
floppy hair music well a lot of times in
sona's case they couldn't have a job
because they were right out of prison
you know or currently in prison a few of
them right yeah I feel they would get a
job they would get a job in the prison
bakery or something or laundry but I
think a prison as a bakery yeah some of
the best baked goods come from
Danbury Connecticut makes a great corn
muffin Cinnabon is a prison released are
you thinking of Paddington too oh my God
I loved Paddington too best movie ever
it's good I Honestly Love Paddington too